Right now, the prevailing attitude is more aligned with your attitude, which is like all the programming languages, like there's not one right way to do things, that all the programming languages have value, and we should all be learning from each other. Welcome to ADSP, the podcast, episode 107, recorded on November 2nd, 2022. My name is Connor and today with my co-host Bryce, we continue part two of our conversation with Jane Lazari-Lesby on the Rust programming language. Be sure to check out part one, link in the description if you haven't yet. So the difference between Intuator and Iter is Intuiter is a trait. Iter is a function with a name that is by convention. And so Intuiter, with a vec, you can take a reference to a vec
目前，普遍的看法更符合你的态度，也就是所有的编程语言，就像没有哪一种是唯一正确的方法一样，所有的编程语言都有价值，我们都应该互相学习。欢迎收看 ADSP 播客，第 107 期，于 2022 年 11 月 2 日录制。我是康纳，今天我的联合主持人布莱斯和我一起，继续我们与简·拉扎里-莱斯比关于 Rust 编程语言对话的第二部分。如果你还没看过第一部分，请务必查看，链接在描述中。那么 into_iter 和 iter 的区别在于，into_iter 是一个特征（trait）。iter 是一个按惯例命名的函数。所以 into_iter，对于一个 vec，你可以获取一个 vec 的引用
and put that in parentheses. So ampersand, vec variable, identifier, parentheses, dot Intuiter. And that will do the reference to into iter trait implementation. So it's like a reference to any type that implements into iter will do, or I think it might actually be a direct implementation on reference to VEC. I'm not positive on that one. Whereas iter is just a free function associated with the vec or possibly the slice type that will just basically do the exact same thing that if you were to give it a reference in front of it, when you call the intuiter, it's going to give you a iterating over references iterator.
并把它放在括号里。也就是 ampersand，vec 变量，标识符，括号，点 into_iter。这将执行对 into_iter 特征的引用实现。所以它就像是对任何实现 into_iter 的类型的引用都可以，或者我想它实际上可能是对 VEC 引用的直接实现。这一点我不太确定。而 iter 只是一个与 vec 或可能是切片类型关联的自由函数，它基本上会做和你在调用 into_iter 时在前面加一个引用完全相同的事情，它将提供一个遍历引用的迭代器。
Whereas you call iter, it's always going to just do the iterating through references iterator. And so calling iter is useful in situations where you don't want to have to deal with like adding that reference at a time you just want the auto ref to like handle getting through going through the slice or dereferencing or whatever is necessary because it's like it knows the exact type it's going to be resulting to versus into iter it's generic receiver and so it can you could run into inference errors sometimes or you might end up like iterating by owner, like owned values or something. And like Intuiter is more flexible in that,
而你调用 iter 时，它总是会执行通过引用遍历的迭代器。因此，在某些情况下调用 iter 很有用，比如你不想在添加那个引用时费事，你只想让自动引用（auto ref）来处理遍历切片或解引用或任何必要的操作，因为它知道它将产生的确切类型，而 into_iter 是泛型接收器，所以有时你可能会遇到推断错误，或者你最终可能会按所有者迭代，比如拥有的值或类似的东西。而 into_iter 在这方面更灵活，
that like you can have like owned iteration or non-owned iteration. And it's actually implicitly called in for loops. So when you put, when you add the iterable item to the, like the second expression, the for. So you have for variable identifier in expression that is expected to be a type that implements into iter. And iterators, the iterator trait is reflexively
比如你可以进行拥有权迭代（owned iteration）或非拥有权迭代（non-owned iteration）。而且它在 for 循环中是被隐式调用的。所以当你把可迭代项放入时，就像把第二个表达式放入 for 循环中一样。所以你有 for 变量标识符 in 表达式，该表达式期望是一个实现 into_iter 的类型。并且迭代器，迭代器特征是自反地
implemented for Intuiter. So if you give it an iterable type, it just automatically is itself. Or I guess that's an identity conversion. And, but like, if you were to just give it a VEC with behind a reference, like a variable name to the VEC behind with an ampersand in front of it, then it will iterate by reference. If you did a mutable reference in front of that VEC,
为 into_iter 实现的。因此，如果你给它一个可迭代的类型，它会自动成为它自己。或者我猜那是一个恒等转换。但是，如果你只是给它一个带引用的 VEC，比如在 VEC 前面带一个 ampersand 的变量名，那么它将通过引用进行迭代。如果你在那个 VEC 前面加一个可变引用，
it would iterate by mutable reference. If you just did the VEC itself, it will take the VEC by like own value, take it apart and iterate by value and destroy the original VEC in the process. And it's like, all you have to do is like what reference you put in front of that variable determines how it gets iterated by the Intuiter trait. Interesting. Yeah, that makes sense. Because I think one of the times that Clippy modified it from an Intuiter to iter was when I was using the Windows function, which I think was returning slices or something like that. So that makes sense then because it was potentially unnecessary what I was doing there.
它将通过可变引用进行迭代。如果你只使用 VEC 本身，它将把 VEC 作为一个拥有的值获取，将其拆开并按值迭代，并在过程中销毁原始 VEC。就像这样，你所需要做的就是你在该变量前面放置的引用决定了它如何被 into_iter 特征迭代。有趣。是的，这说得通。因为我认为 Clippy 将其从 into_iter 修改为 iter 的其中一次，是我正在使用 windows 函数的时候，我想它返回的是切片或类似的东西。所以这说得通，因为我在那里做的事情可能是不必要的。
Cool. I have a question now. How do you write traits in Rust? How do you express a constraint? The way that it's done in C++ I find very quirky. So in C++, it's done essentially through these usage patterns where you say like, oh, suppose I have an object X of this type that I'm constraining. And then you have to be able to be able to call this thing on X and then that thing on X. And if you call this thing on X, it returns this type. So what's it like in Rust? How do I describe a trait in Rust? So it's, I can't remember the formal terms, but basically, instead of describing what the type needs to conform to, it's kind of like an abstract class sort of thing. Like you're describing the interface.
酷。我现在有个问题。你在 Rust 中如何编写特征？你如何表达约束？我发现 C++ 中的做法非常古怪。所以在 C++ 中，它基本上是通过这些使用模式完成的，比如你说，哦，假设我有一个我要约束的这种类型的对象 X。然后你必须能够对 X 调用这个东西，然后对 X 调用那个东西。如果你对 X 调用这个东西，它会返回这个类型。那么在 Rust 中是什么样的？如何在 Rust 中描述一个特征？所以它是，我不记得正式术语了，但基本上，不是描述类型需要符合什么，它有点像抽象类那样的东西。就像你在描述接口一样。
Yes. And when you implement it, you implement that interface within the impl block of the trait. So for like, normally, if you're defining like a free function for a type, you like open up a block that's like impl type and then open block. And within that is where your functions go.
是的。当你实现它时，你是在特征的 impl 块中实现该接口的。比如，通常如果你在为某个类型定义一个自由函数，你会打开一个类似于 impl 类型的块，然后打开一个块。在其中放置你的函数。
And you can like have a self as one of your parameters. And that's going to refer to the type in the impl block etc etc when you're doing the trait function implementations you're going to do impl trait for type and but otherwise it's going to be the same thing but like the functions in there are going to be only the functions that are defined in the trait you can't just put like random functions in there. And if you like implement that exact function in like a just as normal impl block, it doesn't get associated with the trait. It is like it has to be in the traits impl block. And you might be able to have the same function name in two places and then just cause like fun ambiguity errors where
你可以将 self 作为参数之一。那将指代 impl 块中的类型等等，等等。当你进行特征函数实现时，你要做的是 impl trait for type，但除此之外它是一样的，不过那里的函数将仅限于特征中定义的函数，你不能随便把随机函数放进去。如果你在像普通的 impl 块中实现那个确切的函数，它不会与特征关联。它必须在特征的 impl 块中。你可能能够在两个地方拥有相同的函数名，然后就会导致诸如函数歧义错误之类的错误，
you have to like specify the like the long form like at like type as straight colon colon function name or something like that i'm pretty sure that works but not recommended most of the time it's probably just gonna cause problems so that that's sort of how i want to be able to write concepts in c++ but can't and there were proposals at some point in the history of C++ that allowed you to write concepts like that, but they went away, is the polite and simple way to say that. If I could ask a question about C++, how's the pattern matching proposal,
你必须指定长格式，比如类型作为特征双冒号函数名或类似的东西。我很确信这行得通，但不推荐，大多数时候它可能只会导致问题。所以，这就是我想在 C++ 中编写概念但做不到的方式，在 C++ 历史上的某个时期曾有过允许你那样编写概念的提案，但它们消失了，用礼貌且简单的话来说就是这样。如果我可以问一个关于 C++ 的问题，模式匹配提案，
or the patterns proposal going? I know there was like some work there. It's not? it's not. C++ 29? The thing is that a lot of development of a large part of the feature set of C++ has stalled because the C++ committee process was not well prepared for the pandemic and the C++ committee, admirable attempts were made to adjust to the new world. But the reality is that a lot of work stalled out over the past two years.
或者说模式提案进展如何？我知道那里有一些工作。没有？没有。C++ 29？问题在于，C++ 的很大一部分特性集的开发已经陷入停顿，因为 C++ 委员会的流程没有为大流行做好准备，而且 C++ 委员会为了适应新世界做出了令人钦佩的努力。但现实是，过去两年里大量工作停滞不前。
So there's a proposal that two years ago looked like it was on track, but I don't have high hopes for things that have not made progress in the past two years, even if they were in good shape two years ago, because it's disruptive best practices can change i think people are maybe surprised to hear that but that the best practices you know within even within a big language like c++ that moves slowly the best practices do evolve um like we the people who are building language we learn over time um mostly through making mistakes and then we're, you know, we don't want to do that again. So, you know, we should do this instead. And so the best practices evolve.
所以有一个提案在两年前看起来步入正轨，但我对过去两年没有取得进展的事情不抱太高期望，即使它们两年前状态良好也是如此，因为颠覆性的最佳实践可能会改变。我想人们听到这个可能会感到惊讶，但最佳实践，你知道，甚至在像 C++ 这样缓慢发展的大型语言中，最佳实践确实在演变，嗯，就像我们构建语言的人随着时间在学习，嗯，主要是通过犯错误，然后我们，你知道，不想再犯了。所以，你知道，我们应该改做这个。因此，最佳实践在演变。
And then the more time that your thing goes without being updated, the further and further away it is from the state of the art. And that makes it harder for something to come back, even if it was mature before. And I think that this is ultimately what happened to some of the bigger features of CFUS Plus in recent memory that have stalled out or that the committee has in some way rejected. Like the networking TS is one. It was something that was evolved in the mid-2010s and we published a TS on it and we got it pretty close to being ready to go into the standard. But then the best practices changed a lot and then there was resistance to updating it and also it was a big thing.
然后，你的东西没有更新的时间越长，它就离最先进的状态越远。这使得某事物卷土重来变得更加困难，即使它以前很成熟。我认为这最终就是最近记忆中 C++ 的一些较大型特性发生的情况，它们陷入停顿或被委员会以某种方式拒绝。比如网络 TS 就是一个。那是 2010 年代中期发展起来的东西，我们在上面发布了一个 TS，我们让它非常接近准备好进入标准。但随后最佳实践发生了很大变化，然后人们对更新它产生了抵触，而且它也是一个大项目。
So when you've got a big proposal that nobody on the core team has looked at in two years it's going to take a while for everybody to get familiar with the thing again oh yeah um and then that means that it takes longer to get started working on it again and then it becomes more out of date and it just if you're not constantly making progress on a thing uh uh it's more likely than not going to become abandoned yeah yeah no i i i know that from library teamwork like it's the longer the gaps between reviews the the more just the more difficult it is for like everyone involved or it's like we see this a lot um with like software updates like uh at nvidia um it's been a a um a struggle over the years for me to get various internal teams and sdks to move to newer compiler versions and to drop older compiler versions.
所以，当你有了一个核心团队中两年没有人看过的大型提案时，每个人都需要一段时间才能重新熟悉它。哦，是的，嗯，这意味着重新开始着手处理它需要更长的时间，然后它就会变得更加过时，而且，如果你不持续推进一件事情，嗯，它更有可能会被废弃。是的，是的，不，我从库的团队合作中知道这一点——审查之间的间隔越长，对所有相关人员来说就越困难，或者我们经常看到这一点——就像软件更新一样——比如在英伟达，多年来对我来说，让各种内部团队和 SDK 转向较新的编译器版本并放弃较旧的编译器版本一直是一场，嗯，斗争。
And one thing that we repeatedly see is that if you update from upstream once a month versus once a year, you're actually doing less work if you're doing it once a month. You might think, oh, well, we update once a year and it'll be 12 times as much work than updating once a month. But it's actually probably more like 20 times or 40 times because the cost of making all those changes all at once instead of doing them incrementally is far greater. You're not able to start making changes naturally as things evolve. You end up in the situation where you're like, oh, now we have to do this whole big refactor to update to the newer thing.
我们反复看到的一件事是，如果你一个月从上游更新一次与一年更新一次相比，如果你一个月更新一次，你实际做的工作更少。你可能会想，哦，好吧，我们一年更新一次，工作量将是每月更新一次的 12 倍。但实际上可能更像是 20 倍或 40 倍，因为一次性进行所有这些更改而不是循序渐进地进行，其成本要高得多。随着事情的发展，你无法自然地开始进行更改。你最终会陷入这样一种境地，你会想，哦，现在我们必须进行这次重大的重构来更新到更新的东西。
And then, of course, that takes time and then that means that it's longer until you've updated to the newer thing then there's more changes that you have to deal with and again you end up in this uh death spiral of uh of sadness i mean on that negative note you did still highlight it in your top three bryce just gave a keynote a week ago at o3d con in texas and one of his top three future c++ features was pattern matching so yeah it's good stuff those top three features that i highlighted were um a reflection um pattern matching and um and senders and uh i mean there's like channels yeah more or less yeah i'm gonna say yeah and there are a bunch of people who i work with who um may be upset at me but yeah you have the basic idea
然后，当然，这需要时间，这意味着在你更新到更新的东西之前需要更长的时间，然后你必须处理更多的更改，同样，你最终会陷入这种悲伤的死亡螺旋。嗯，顺便说一句，布莱斯，你在德克萨斯州的 o3d 展会上刚做了一场主题演讲，你确实在你的前三大未来 C++ 特性中强调了模式匹配，所以，是的，这是好东西。我强调的那前三大特性是，嗯，反射、模式匹配以及，嗯，发送者（senders）和，我的意思是，就像通道（channels）一样，或多或少，是的，我要说，是的，有一群与我共事的人可能会生我的气，但，是的，你有基本概念。
okay um but yeah i mean i think those are are the most transformative things that C++ could do outside of, you know, obviously I think the whole question of package ecosystem is probably more transformative. I've said for like a while, the single most important thing C++ Committee could do is to figure out a story for the packaging ecosystem and then improving the C++ Committee evolution process.
好的，嗯，但是，是的，我的意思是，我认为这些是 C++ 除了，你知道，显然我认为包生态系统的整个问题可能更具变革性之外，能够做的最具变革性的事情。我有一段时间一直在说，C++ 委员会能做的最重要的一件事情就是弄清楚包生态系统的方案，然后改进 C++ 委员会的演变流程。
I saw something on Twitter earlier today that really stuck with me, which was something in the effect of junior engineers think about how are we going to solve this technical problem? How are we going to do this thing? How are we going to execute this thing? Whereas senior engineers think about, is this team positioned for success? Do they have the support that they need? Are their metrics and their KPIs set up in a way
我今天早些时候在 Twitter 上看到了一些东西，真的让我深有感触，大意是：初级工程师思考的是，我们要如何解决这个技术问题？我们要如何做这件事？我们要如何执行这件事？而高级工程师思考的是，这个团队是否处于成功的位置？他们是否有他们需要的支持？他们的指标和关键绩效指标（KPI）的设置方式
that they're going to be successful? Are they happy, etc.? That really came true with me. That's one of the reasons why I care so much about the health and the...
是否能让他们取得成功？他们是否快乐，等等。这对我来说真的很真实。这也是我如此关心一个项目的健康状况以及……的原因。
What's the word I'm looking for? And the modernness of the evolution process of a project. Because if your thing can't evolve and improve, it doesn't matter how good it is. Eventually, other things that can evolve and improve faster will outpace it. Preaching to the choir. Yeah. I didn't mean, I didn't even, when I was listening off all this stuff, I didn't even mention, yeah, the package system crates.io. Yeah. Although I do have a bone to pick with rust here oh um so my understanding is that the rust uh crate system is
我要找的词是什么？以及项目演变流程的现代化程度。因为如果你的东西不能演变和改进，不管它有多好，最终其他能够更快演变和改进的东西将超越它。这是老生常谈了。是的。我不是指，当我列出所有这些东西时，我甚至没有提到，是的，包系统 crates.io。是的。虽然我对 Rust 确实有点意见，哦，嗯，据我理解，Rust 的包系统
uh still as a model where everything is built from source yes yes and there's no binary distribution? No, but they're looking at starting a project right now for a safe AVI. So we're going to look into trying to find a way to have a subset of the language that we can expose as a stable AVI without having the entire Dyn linked AVI be stabilized? Yeah. So my bone to pick here is essentially, I don't think it's sustainable in the long term to have a package ecosystem that's solely from source. And it's for two reasons. One is a scale. As you get up to building at larger and larger scales, it's increasingly difficult to build everything from source. Now, of course, for a language like Rust, where the static analysis is sort of a key element of the language, this is, of course, a challenge. But the other piece is closed source code, which, while I am an open source person and have pretty much only worked on open source projects my entire career, including most of my time at NVIDIA, you know, the reality is that closed source is out there. And I think for Rust to be truly successful and
仍然采用一切都从源码构建的模型吗？是的，是的。没有二进制分发？没有，但他们现在正在着手启动一个关于安全 ABI 的项目。所以我们将研究寻找一种方法，拥有语言的一个子集，我们可以将其公开为稳定的 ABI，而无需稳定整个动态链接的 ABI？是的。所以我在这里的意见基本上是，我认为拥有一个完全来自源码的包生态系统在长期来看是不可持续的。原因有二。一是规模。当你构建的规模越来越大时，从源码构建一切变得越来越困难。现在，当然，对于像 Rust 这样的语言，其静态分析可以说是语言的关键要素，这当然是一个挑战。但另一部分是闭源代码，虽然我是一个开源人士，而且几乎我的整个职业生涯都在从事开源项目，包括在英伟达的大部分时间，你知道，现实是闭源是客观存在的。而且我认为 Rust 要想真正成功并
become a top, you know, five or a top three language, it will need to support that part of the ecosystem as well. And, you know, I think for Rust really to truly become one of those top languages it's not sufficient to just have all those closed source projects be limited to oh well you have to expose your closed source stuff through a C-ABI
成为前五或前三的语言，它也需要支持生态系统的这一部分。而且，你知道，我认为 Rust 要想真正成为那些顶级语言之一，仅仅让所有这些闭源项目局限于“哦，好吧，你必须通过 C-ABI 公开你的闭源东西”
you know or C++ ABI I think people are going to want to write things natively in Rust and so that is one thing that I have said for a few years, I would expect Rust to evolve on. And I'm glad to see that there's now some movement in that direction. Not as fiery of a debate as i was
或者 C++ ABI 是不够的，我认为人们会想要在 Rust 中原生编写东西。所以这是我几年来一直说的一件事，我期望 Rust 会朝这个方向演变。我很高兴看到现在有一些朝着那个方向发展的迹象。这并不是一场像我
as i was aiming for we're all just like yeah this yeah it's working on it i mean it's a baby project it's like a long way from like even even having anything to show for it yet but it's it's definitely there's you're not the only person i think who wants that I definitely am much more on the open source side but so like I have like it's not my priority to work on support close support stuff personally though I understand that people want to work that way I just don't think it's as effective a way to work
所瞄准的那样激烈的辩论，我们都只是觉得，是的，这个，是的，它正在努力。我的意思是，这是一个初期的项目，距离甚至有什么成果可以展示还有很长的路要走，但它绝对是存在的，我想你不是唯一一个想要这个的人。我绝对更多地站在开源这一边，所以就像我有——支持闭源东西对我个人来说不是我的优先事项，虽然我理解人们想要那样工作，但我只是认为这不是一种有效的工作方式。
but you know we don't need to get into the ideological debate and yeah it's there's definitely plenty of reasons even beyond those like just like binary size like being able to not have like the same dependency duplicated in every application that uses it and things like that where it's like rust needs to be able to do it and so there's there's no there's no debate there yeah so jane do you remember um that we actually met uh once before and i think it was at an lvm yeah lvm developer meetup 2019 i think yeah that sounds right yeah uh and i don't i think at the time you were just like starting your your rust explorations you weren't like a full convert yet no i was yeah
但你知道，我们不需要陷入意识形态的辩论，而且，是的，除了那些之外，还有很多原因，比如仅仅是二进制文件大小——能够避免在每个使用它的应用程序中重复相同的依赖项等等，在这些方面，Rust 需要能够做到这一点，所以没有，没有辩论，是的。所以简，你还记得，我们实际上在之前见过一次，我想那是在一个 LLVM，是的，2019 年的 LLVM 开发者聚会上，我想，是的，听起来对，是的。而且我不知道，我想当时你刚刚开始探索 Rust，你还不是一个完全的皈依者，对吧？不，我是，是的。
it was still that was still when i worked at scale so i was still a professional c++ developer i think i was like quite well and deeply into the hyper focus on rust yeah so i was like you know not not necessarily on like on the lips team or anything like that yet um i think i was i think i might have already been on the Clippy team at that point. I remember hanging out with Tyler. I think you were because I seem to recall you talking with great glee about Clippy.
那还是我在 Scale 工作的时候，所以我仍然是一个专业的 C++ 开发者。我想我当时已经非常深入地专注于 Rust 了，是的。所以我当时就像是，你知道，不一定在核心团队（libs team）里或者别的什么地方；我想我当时可能已经在 Clippy 团队里了。我记得和泰勒一起玩。我想你是的，因为我依稀记得你非常高兴地谈论 Clippy。
Thanks. It was a good time. I enjoyed that trip. Connor, what else should we talk about? There's the Shinkansen no no we're not we're not getting we're not getting to that yet so i recently heard bjarne strustrup i got i gotta share something that my girlfriend just texted me and i gotta i have to just appeared i just have to pray to god that she never listens to this podcast oh no
谢谢。那是一段美好的时光。我很享受那次旅行。康纳，我们还应该聊点什么？有新干线……不，不，我们不谈这个，我们还没到那一步。所以，我最近听到本贾尼·斯特劳斯特鲁普（Bjarne Stroustrup）——我得分享一下我女朋友刚刚发给我的短信，我必须发出来，我只能祈求上帝她永远不会听到这个播客。哦，不。
so um does this have a backstory i thought you're just gonna read us a text my guy it has a backstory we have how long is this our dog our dog oh my goodness very smart oh my goodness i can't i'm not airing this i'm not airing this and i just got a text from the girlfriend this is the worst literally you know so this is what happened jane bryce has just gone downhill as the co-host ever since episode zero and so the beginning no no i went i went i went up because episode zero i didn't have a proper microphone then i bought the good microphone so then episode one that was really where it peaked
所以，嗯，这有什么背景故事吗？我以为你只是要给我们读一条短信，老兄。它有背景故事。我们有……我们的狗有多大？我们的狗，哦天哪，非常聪明，哦天哪，我不能，我不能把这个播报出去，我不能把这个播报出去。我刚刚收到女朋友的短信，这太糟糕了，字面意思，你知道，所以发生了什么，简，自从第 0 期以来，布莱斯作为联合主持人的表现就一直在走下坡路，所以从一开始……不，不，我上去了，我上去了，因为第 0 期我没有一个合适的麦克风，然后我买了好麦克风，所以在第 1 期，那真的是达到了顶峰。
and from there so when you said episode 101 that wasn't like a this is a vinnik intercourse this is like the beginning of the rust learning it was actually the hundredth and first that was a hundred and first episode yeah did you aim that to be oh no that was totally an accident and i'm just realizing now that the 101 episode correspond to us trying to learn stuff that was literally totally you trying to learn something and me apparently teaching it to you yeah but i've been threatening bryce for like episode 90 to 100 when we had kate gregory on uh because bryce was like eating his dinner and kept on interrupting and you know asked kate a question about the cabin she was in let her get
从那以后——所以当你说是第 101 期时，那不是像这是一个交替，这就像是 Rust 学习的开始，实际上那是第一百零一期。那是第一百零一期，是的。你是故意要那样的吗？哦，不，那完全是个意外，我直到现在才意识到第 101 期对应着我们试图学习一些东西，那字面意思完全是你试图学习某些东西，而我显然在教你，是的。但从第 90 到 100 期左右，当我们在节目中邀请了凯特·格雷戈里（Kate Gregory）时，我就一直在威胁布莱斯，因为布莱斯当时在吃晚饭，并且不断打断谈话，你知道的，问了凯特一个关于她所在的木屋的问题，让她在问题里说出了
four words into the question and then like interrupted her to tell her something about his dog and i was like bryce what are you doing and then i said you're on you're on thin ice and then i said i'm gonna start trying out new co-hosts. Then I went and did. I tried out a new co-host, former co-host of CppCast, Jason Turner. And then Bryce, last week, said because I
四个字，然后就打断了她，跟她讲了一些关于他的狗的事情，当时我就想：布莱斯，你在干什么？然后我说：你现在如履薄冰。然后我说：我要开始寻找新的联合主持人了。然后我就去了。我找了一个新联合主持人，CppCast 的前联合主持人杰森·特纳（Jason Turner）。然后布莱斯上周说，因为我
indicated that I might have recorded without him. And then I could just tell Bryce was heartbroken. He was just like, don't record without me. And now here I am being like, you know what? I did the right thing, Bryce. You're back on thin ice. Except this might not even air because people are just going to be confused on why I'm giving you a hard time. Because they won't have heard the story that you just told.
暗示我可能在没有他的情况下进行了录音。然后我能看出布莱斯心碎了。他就像是：别在没有我的情况下录音。而现在我在这里就像是：你知道吗？我做对了，布莱斯。你又开始如履薄冰了。除了这甚至可能都不会播出，因为人们会感到困惑，为什么我要给你难堪。因为他们没有听过你刚刚讲的故事。
It's inappropriate, Bryce. Clean up your act. You can just like cut right after. He's like, I'm going gonna tell you the story and then just cut to like we're not airing that all right back to the question that i had so this is going to be we're entering hot take territory we'll see what we can get out uh from jane recently on episode uh 155 which really they only started it recording them at like episode 120 of another podcast called C++ Club.
这很不合适，布莱斯。收敛点。你可以直接在他说“我要告诉你这个故事”之后剪辑掉，然后直接切到——我们不会播出那个的。好吧，回到我的问题。所以这将是——我们正在进入火辣观点（hot take）的领域，我们将看看能从简那里得到什么。最近在另一档名为 C++ Club 的播客的第 155 期中（实际上他们大约在第 120 期才开始录制），
Bjarne Stroustrup, they just, it's like a Zoom meeting and they just record it. So Bjarne sometimes joins, creator of the C++ language. I assume everyone knows that. And at some point in the podcast, it comes, Bjarne ends up saying, I don't even really remember the lead up to it. They end up making a joke about Rust, saying that, oh, Rust is good
本贾尼·斯特劳斯特鲁普，他们只是，这就像是一个 Zoom 会议，他们录制下来。所以本贾尼有时会加入，C++ 语言的创造者。我假设每个人都知道这一点。然后在播客的某个时刻，本贾尼最终说——我甚至不记得前面的铺垫了——他们最终对 Rust 开了个玩笑，说哦， Rust 很好，
because we don't want to get like, you know, downvoted on the internet by saying something bad about Rust. And then Bjarne says, oh yes, the Rust community is much better at propaganda than C++.
因为我们不想在互联网上因为说 Rust 的坏话而被踩（downvoted）。然后本贾尼说，哦是的，Rust 社区在宣传（propaganda）方面比 C++ 做得好得多。
The Rust people are very, very good at propaganda. Far, far better than the C++ crowd. And I was a bit confused because I've only been dabbling around in this language for like a week and a bit. And from my experience, it's just better in a lot of ways.
Rust 的人们非常非常擅长宣传。远比 C++ 那群人擅长得多。我当时有点困惑，因为我涉足这门语言只有一周多一点的时间。从我的经验来看，它在很多方面都更好。
That doesn't seem like propaganda to me. That just seems like you got a better story. So I think Bjarne is almost certainly referring to what I talked about earlier, which is the memory safety thing. That, that... How's that propaganda, though? Because for whatever reason, I think some uh of the in the c++ community feel that um that the memory safety aspect of rust is nonsense in some way or that we can achieve
这对我来说不像是宣传。这只意味着你们有一个更好的故事。所以我认为本贾尼几乎可以肯定是 nivel 刚才我谈到的那件事，也就是内存安全问题。那，那……不过怎么能说是宣传呢？因为不管出于什么原因，我认为 C++ 社区中的一些人觉得，嗯，Rust 的内存安全方面在某种程度上是无稽之谈，或者我们可以在 C++ 中实现
the same effect in c++ or something to that effect but but but my But my strong suspicion is that what was meant by that is a hyper-focus on the question of memory safety. And I'll prove it to you, because almost all of the response
相同的效果或类似的效果，但是，但是，但是我的强烈直觉是，那句话的意思是对内存安全问题的过度关注。我向你证明这一点，因为来自像本贾尼这样的人对 Rust 的几乎所有回应都围绕着改进 C++ 中的内存安全。就像，哦，人们担心，你知道，这一个方面。这就是问题所在。这就是 C++ 的问题所在，它不是一门内存安全的语言。如果我们解决了这个问题，那么 C++ 的所有问题都将得到解决。一切都会完美。
from somebody like Bjarne to Rust has been around improving memory safety in C++. Like, oh, people are concerned about, you know, this one aspect. This is the problem. This is the problem with C++, that it's not a memory-safe language. And if we solve that problem, then all of C++'s problems will be solved. Everything will be perfect.
简怎么看？还有，顺便补充一下这个问题，因为你身处 Rust 社区内部，并且是几个 Rust 团队的一部分。在 Rust 内部，你是否知道 Rust 外部的人认为你们有一个宣传机器？
What's Jane? Jane, what's your take? And also to layer on top of the question, because you're inside the Rust community and like part of a couple of the Rust teams. Is there like inside of Rust, are you aware that people outside of Rust think that you guys have a propaganda machine?
好吧，好吧。这是一个人的看法，一个人。我的意思是，我确实有一种感觉，就像一个宣传机器。好吧，好吧。这是一个人的看法。一个人。我的意思是，我确实有一种感觉，就像很多 C++ 开发者，特别是在 sub-reddit，C++ 子版块上，他们只是，他们不想听到任何关于 Rust 的消息。就像，他们对 Rust 开发者所分享的东西以及 Rust 人学到的教训不感兴趣。作为一个热爱所有编程语言的语言多面手（polyglot），包括，你知道，一些
Well, okay, okay. This is one person, one person. I mean, I do get a sense that like a propaganda machine. Well, okay, okay. This is one person. One person. I mean, I do get a sense that, like, a lot of C++, especially on slash the subreddit, C++ subreddit, like, they just, they don't want to hear anything about Rust. Like, they're uninterested in what Rust devs and the lessons that Rust people have learned have to share. And as, like, a polyglot that loves all programming languages, including, you know, some of the
最受人讨厌的编程语言，比如 Perl，我爱 Perl。Perl 很棒。你知道，在很多方面与 Python 非常相似，而人们似乎拒绝承认这一点。但无论如何，所以我发现这样做只是在伤害我们。所以我只是很好奇，从一个 Rust 内部人士的角度来看，这对你来说是新闻吗？Rust 社区内部的人知道吗？你有什么内部细节可以分享吗？我确信我很想听听，我的一些
most widely hated programming languages like Perl, I love Perl. Perl's great. You know, very similar to Python in a lot of ways that people seem to be refusing to acknowledge. But anyway, so I find that kind of just like, that's just hurting us by doing that. And so I'm just interested, interested like from like a rust insider's point of view is this news to you does do people inside the rust community are they are they aware and any inside details you could share i'm sure i know i would be interested to hear and some of
听众肯定也想听。所以在 Rust 社区里有一个梗（meme），我想你可以谷歌一下，看到一些非常美丽、非常有趣和搞笑的蒸汽波（vaporwave）艺术——关于 Rust 宣传特遣队（Rust Evangelism Strike Force, RESF），这是一个真实存在的东西吗？是的，甚至还有相关的子版块，嗯——所以我们绝对非常清楚这种，这种看法，而且我认为绝对有，我认为 Rust 有一种倾向，当人们接触它时会让他们感到非常兴奋，所以你会发现项目里的人并没有到处去进行激进的宣传，我认为如果你看看实际的项目贡献者，他们往往相当保守。我想他们——我认为目前普遍的看法更符合
our listeners i'm sure so there's a meme in the rust community and i think you can google this and see some really beautiful some really funny and hilarious vaporwave art um about the rust evangelism strike force the resf there's this a real thing yeah there's like subreddits to it too um so we're definitely very aware of this uh this kind of perception and i think there's definitely i think rust has a tendency to to get people really excited when they get into it and so like you won't find people on the project going around and evangelizing aggressively i think like if you look at like actual project contributors they're they tend to be pretty reserved i think they're i think right now the prevailing attitude is more aligned with
你的态度，也就是所有的编程语言，就像没有哪一种是唯一正确的方法一样，所有的编程语言都有价值，我们都应该互相学习，但是，像特别是一些非常兴奋的新人，他们更有可能到处跑，然后问：你听说过 Rust 吗？类似这样的事情确实会发生，我的意思是，而且我确信 C++ 开发者会看到其他正在了解 Rust 的 C++ 开发者走过来并说：嗯，你应该用 Rust 重写，那会解决你遇到的这一个 bug 或类似的问题，这就好像是，你知道，这并不总是最有帮助的建议，而且可能会让人精疲力竭，而且绝对可以说，甚至在项目内部，也有人对人们
your attitude which is like all the programming languages like there's not one right way to do things that all the programming languages have value and we should all be learning from each other and that but like especially people like new people who are really excited they're a lot more likely to be like running around and being like have you heard of rust and like that that does happen i mean and i'm sure that c++ developers see like other c++ developers who are learning about rust coming in and being like well you should have rewritten a rust that would have solved this this one bug you ran into or something and it's like you know not always the most helpful suggestion and it can be exhausting and there's definitely i would say even like within the project like a pushback against people
真正参与 Rust 宣传特遣队或者“用 Rust 重写”这类梗并支持这种行为进行回推（pushback），因为这可能会有点适得其反，而且，嗯，绝对更倾向于相互支持其他社区并保持尊重——所以我们不喜欢——我不认为在 Rust 项目内部有活跃的宣传，绝对没有活跃的宣传机器。我的意思是，我认为过去有时我们做得更好，特别是在我们做 1.0 的时候。我认为他们在营销方面要有效得多。我认为现在有更多的混乱，我们在那方面没有那么协调。
like actually engaging in like the rust evangelism strike force or like rewriting and rust memes and like kind of supporting that because it can be like a bit counterproductive and um definitely a preference for kind of mutually supporting other communities and being respectful um so we don't we like i don't think there is actively there's there's definitely no active propaganda machine within the Rust project. Like, I think there are times in the past where we've been a lot better, especially like when we were doing 1.0. I think they were a lot more effective at marketing. I think these days there's there's a lot more chaos and we're not as coordinated in that regard.
这是我们正在努力的事情，我们——如果你看博客上的博客文章，在过去的一年里有多篇关于在顶级更新 Rust 治理的博客文章，这也是我参与过的一个方面，嗯，我为此感到非常兴奋。这就好像是，布莱斯，当你在谈论实现有效的语言演变时，这简直说到了我的心坎里，因为，是的，我认为我理解能够建立一个让人们能够有效合作的环境有多么重要，这也是我们也在挣扎的事情——我知道你觉得 Rust 拥有这一切——就像目前真的很好一样。我的确认为我们可能处于一个更好的位置，区别在于，嗯，至少我知道最近在 Rust 的演变和领导层方面确实存在一些问题，我看到的区别是解决和改进事情的意愿。我没有看到 C++……你刚才说，对不起，是的，就像是同理心（empathizing）而不是道歉（apologizing），这太棒了，这——我以为你刚才低声说了，
And it's something that we're working on we like if you if you look on the blog post on the blog there's like multiple blog posts over the last year about updating rust governance at the top level which is one thing i've been involved in um and i'm very excited about and this is like when you're talking bryce about like getting the effective language evolution this was like kind of speaking to my heart because like yeah i think i understand how important it is to be able to set up an environment where people can collaborate effectively and it's something that like we struggle with too like i know you you feel like rust has it all like just like really good at the moment i do think like we're probably in a better spot the i think the difference is um the at least i'm aware that there have been some problems
然后我就想：哦，哇，这太好了，你就像是，我——这很不幸，因为事实确实如此。谢谢收听，希望你们喜欢，祝大家有美好的一天。本期节目暂无评论。点击转录文本中的任意句子即可发表评论。
in Rust evolution and leadership as of late the difference that I see is the willingness to address and improve things I don't see that the C++ did you say i'm sorry yeah like empathizing not apologizing that's amazing that's i thought you like kind of whispered that
在最近Rust的发展和领导层中，我看到的区别在于他们愿意去解决和改进问题，我没看到C++也这样做，你刚才说的是抱歉吗？是的，就像是共情而不是道歉，太棒了，我还以为你刚才小声说来着
and i was like oh wow like that's very nice that you're like i uh that's unfortunate because it is thanks for listening we hope you enjoyed and have a great day There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
然后我就想，哇，你这样说真好，我呃，这挺遗憾的，因为事实确实如此。感谢收听，我们希望你喜欢本期节目，祝你拥有美好的一天。本期节目暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。